Keep yourself and your family safe by practicing spring cleaning safety.
You will need: vinegar, water, a computer with Internet access,...
...emergency phone numbers, a working smoke detector, and an escape plan.
Step 1: Opt for nontoxic cleaning products such as water and vinegar.
Vinegar is inexpensive and can be used for a number of household cleaning projects.
Step 2: Check for recalled children products at recalls.gov.
Step 3: Make sure flammable liquids such as paint thinner, gasoline, and other cleaners...
...are kept far away from any heat source.
Make sure the safety caps are secure on all cleaning products.
Step 4: Post the poison help line, police, fire department, and your doctor's phone number near all your phones in case of emergency.
Step 5: Check your smoke detector manual for any spring cleaning maintenance.
Batteries should be replaced once a year in smoke detectors.
Step 6: Clean up old rags, debris, and loose papers that can contribute to a fire.
Store matches, candles, and lighters away from the reach of children.
Step 7: Keep your family safe by checking for sharp edges, tripping hazards, and poisonous plants around your yard.
Practice an escape plan in case of an emergency.
Did you know, chlorine gas was used as a chemical weapon in World War I?